(Applaudissements)
Je voudrais vous parler du « contenu généré par les utilisateurs ».
Je vais vous raconter trois histoires qui m'amèneront à une conclusion
qui vous expliquera brièvement
comment tirer profit du « contenu généré par les utilisateurs. »
Première histoire.
1906. Cet homme, John Philip Sousa, voyagea jusqu’ici,
au congrès des États-Unis, pour parler de cette technologie
qu'il appelait « Les Machines qui parlent. »
Sousa n'était pas un grand adepte des Machines qui parlent.
Écoutez plutôt.
« Ces Machines parlantes ruineront le développement artistique musical du pays.
Quand j'étais un garçon, sur le parvis de chaque maison les soirs d'été
on entendait des jeunes chantants ensemble les chansons du jour, ou celles d'avant.
Aujourd'hui, on entend ces machines infernales jour et nuit.
Bientôt, il ne nous restera plus une corde vocale », disait Sousa.
« Les cordes vocales seront éliminées par le procédé de l'évolution,
comme elle ôta à l'homme la queue du singe. »
Aujourd'hui, j'attire votre attention sur cette image.
C'est une image de la culture.
On pourrait la décrire avec les termes de l'informatique moderne
comme une culture read-write (lire et écrire)
où les gens participent à sa création et à son enrichissement : en cela, elle est read-write.
Sousa avait peur que nous perdions cette capacité
à cause de « ces machines infernales », qui nous la prendraient.
Et qu'à la place, nous soyons à l'opposé de la culture read-write,
dans une culture « read-only » (à lecture seule).
Une culture où la créativité est consommée,
mais où le consommateur n'est plus créateur.
Une culture imposée et possédée d'en haut,
où des millions de cordes vocales ont été perdues.
Maintenant, si vous observez le 20e siècle,
au moins dans les « pays développés », force est de constater qu'il avait raison.
Jamais auparavant dans l’Histoire, la culture de l'humanité
n’a été si professionnalisée, si concentrée,
jamais la créativité de millions de gens n'a été si efficacement supplantée,
à cause de ces « machines infernales ».
Le 20e siècle fut le siècle où,
au moins dans ces pays que nous connaissons le mieux,
la culture est passée de read-write à read-only.
Seconde histoire. La terre est un bien de propriété, protégée par la loi.
Comme lord Blackstone le décrivait, la terre est protégée par la « loi contre les intrus. »
Longtemps, cette « loi contre les intrus »
présumait qu'elle protégeait l'espace souterrain
et au-dessus de la terre, jusqu'à l'infini.
C'était pratique pour la régulation du territoire,
jusqu'à l'arrivée de cette technologie, et l’on commença à se demander
ces engins étaient-ils des intrus ?
lorsqu'ils survolaient les terres sans autorisation des fermiers,
lorsqu'ils traversaient le pays ?
Hé bien en 1945, la Cour Suprême trancha la question.
Deux fermiers, Thomas Lee et Tinie Cosby, qui élevaient des poulets
avaient une plainte significative à l'encontre de ces technologies :
leurs poulets suivaient l'exemple des avions
en se jetant en l'air contre les murs de la ferme à leur passage.
Se référant à cette loi, ils affirmèrent que ces avions étaient des intrus.
Depuis toujours, la loi disait que nul ne pouvait
survoler la terre sans la permission du propriétaire,
ces vols devaient donc cesser.
La Cour Suprême reconsidéra cette loi vieille de 100 ans,
et affirma, dans un délibéré écrit par Justice Douglass,
que les Cosbys devaient perdre.
La Cour Suprême affirma que la doctrine protégeant la terre
jusqu'aux cieux n'avait plus sa place dans le monde moderne,
sinon chaque vol pourrait être poursuivi,
chaque compagnie aérienne attaquée.
Le bon sens, une idée rare en loi, mais là, ce n'était que du bon sens.
(Rires)
Le bon sens s'y refuse.
Dernière histoire. Avant Internet, la dernière horreur
qui allait s'abattre sur l'industrie des contenus
était créée par cette technologie : la radio.
Une nouvelle façon de transmettre du contenu
et donc une nouvelle bataille sur le contrôle
des acteurs qui le transmettraient.
À cette époque, la société, le cartel légal qui contrôlait les droits des artistes
pour la majorité de la musique diffusée avec ces technologies était l'ASCAP.
Ils avaient une licence exclusive sur les contenus les plus demandés,
et ils exercèrent leur contrôle de façon à montrer
aux radios qui était vraiment le patron.
De 1931 à 1939, ils augmentèrent leur tarif de 448 %,
jusqu'à ce que les radios finalement se réunissent et disent : cela suffit !
Et en 1939, un avocat, Sydnay Kaye lança une société
baptisée Broadcast Music Incorporated, connue sous le nom BMI.
BMI était plus démocratique dans le choix des artistes, dans les genres de son répertoire,
avec de la musique Afro-américaine, une première à l'époque.
Mais plus important encore, BMI prit des œuvres du domaine public
et en fit des arrangements gratuits pour leurs clients.
Si bien qu'en 1940 quand Ascap menaça de doubler ses tarifs,
la majorité des radios se tourna vers BMI.
L'ASCAP affirma que peu importait :
les auditeurs se révolteraient, car la meilleure musique
de leur répertoire n'était plus disponible,
les radios s'étant tournées vers le fournisseur n° 2, BMI.
Hé bien, le public ne se révolta pas, et en 1941, l'ASCAP fit faillite.
Et le point à important à noter
est que bien que ces radios diffusaient de la musique « de moindre qualité »,
cette concurrence suffit à briser, à l'époque,
ce cartel légal qui contrôlait l'accès à la musique.
Trois histoires. Voici ma conclusion.
De mon point de vue, le plus important dans ce que l'Internet change,
c'est cette occasion de faire revivre la culture read-write
que Sousa affectionnait tant.
La technologie numérique est une chance de faire revivre ces cordes vocales
dont il parlait avec tant de passion au Congrès.
Le contenu généré par les utilisateurs s'est répandu dans les entreprises
de façon tout à fait remarquable, en reconnaissant la culture amateur.
Culture amateur, qui ne veut pas dire amateurisme.
J'entends par culture amateur, une culture où les gens font par plaisir et non pour l'argent,
une culture produite par vos enfants, continuellement.
Lorsqu'on repense à ce que Sousa affectionnait,
dans cette jeunesse réunie par le chant,
nous devrions reconnaitre ce que nos enfants font en ce moment :
prendre les chansons du jour et d'avant et les remanier pour en faire autre chose.
C'est leur façon d'accéder à cette culture.
Je vais vous montrer quelques exemples de ce dont je parle.
Mon 1er exemple est un « Anime Music Video »,
ce sont des dessins animés télé remontés sur une bande-son musicale.
(Musique)
Ici, ne vous inquiétez pas : Jésus survit.
(Musique : « I Will Survive » par Gloria Gaynor)
(Rires)
Et mon préféré.
(Musique : « Endless Love » par Lionel Ritchie et Diana Ross)
Mon amour...
Il n'y a que toi dans ma vie...
Ma seule et unique lumière...
Mon amour...
Tu es dans toutes mes inspirations...
Tu es dans chaque pas que je fais...
Et je...
Je veux partager tout cet amour avec toi...
Personne d'autre n'est à la hauteur...
Et tes yeux...
Ils me disent combien tout cela compte pour toi...
(Musique)
C'est ce qu'on appelle un remix.
(Applaudissements)
Et il faut souligner que ce n'est pas du « piratage ».
Je ne parle pas de, ni ne justifie ceux qui prennent des œuvres intégrales
et les redistribuent sans autorisation des auteurs.
Je parle ici de gens qui prennent du contenu
pour en recréer avec les techniques numériques,
pour dire les choses différemment.
Et l'important ici, ce n'est pas la technique.
Car, bien sûr, la télévision et le cinéma pratiquent toutes ces techniques
depuis 50 ans.
L'important c'est que cette technique a été démocratisée.
N'importe qui avec un ordinateur à 1500 $
peut récupérer sons et images pour dire les choses autrement.
Ces outils de créativité sont des outils du langage.
C'est l'abécédaire de cette génération. C'est comme ça que nos enfants parlent.
C'est comme ça qu'ils pensent. C'est ce qu'ils sont devenus,
en comprenant de mieux en mieux ces technologies numériques
et leur lien avec elles.
En réponse à ce nouvel usage numérique de la culture,
la loi n'a pas accueilli cette créativité qu'aimait tant Sousa,
avec beaucoup de bon sens.
Le lien entre architectures du copyright et des technologies numériques
a amené à présumer que ces activités étaient illégales.
Puisque la loi du copyright régit la copie,
et que dans l'univers du numérique, on ne peut pas ignorer
que chaque utilisation engendre une copie.
Donc, toute utilisation nécessite autorisation, sous peine d'être un intrus.
Vous êtes un intrus, comme ces gens-là étaient des intrus.
Le bon sens ne s'est pas encore révolté contre ce que la loi a offert en réponse
à ces formes de créativités.
En fait, ce qui se passe est bien pire qu'une révolte.
De chaque côté, se développe un extrémisme en réponse à ce conflit
entre la loi et l'usage.
D'un côté, on construit de nouvelles techniques,
comme celle annoncée récemment pour ôter automatiquement de sites comme YouTube
tout ce qui a le moindre copyright, qu'un « usage raisonnable »
s'applique ou pas.
Et de l'autre côté, parmi nos enfants,
grandit l'idée qu'il faut abolir le copyright,
c'est une génération qui rejette la notion même
de protection des œuvres et de copyright, qui pense que la Loi n'est qu'un âne,
un âne à ignorer et combattre à chaque occasion.
L'extrémisme d'un côté attise l'extrémisme de l'autre côté,
un classique que nous aurions dû apprendre, à maintes reprises,
et chaque extrême dans ce débat a tort.
Je vais vous présenter l'équilibre que je défends.
En bon démocrate, j'ai commencé par me tourner vers le gouvernement. Erreur complète !
(Rires)
J'ai été en salle d'audience et à l'assemblée, pour défendre un système plus censé.
Cela n'a pas marché : la justice est trop passive, et les députés trop corrompus.
Je ne veux pas dire par là
que de la corruption empêcherait un changement,
mais que le climat d'influences qui gouverne le Congrès
fait que le législateur ne comprendra le problème que trop tard.
Nous avons besoin d'autre chose, d'une autre solution :
C'est, à mon sens, une solution privée,
une solution qui essaie de légaliser ce que c'est d'être jeune,
et exploite ce potentiel économique,
et c'est là que l'histoire de BMI est pertinente.
Car comme BMI l'a démontré, la concurrence
peut arriver à un équilibre. Ce qui peut s'appliquer aujourd'hui.
Nous n'avons pas le domaine public pour nous y aider aujourd'hui,
il nous faut à la place deux types de changement.
Il faut d'abord que les artistes et les créateurs acceptent l'idée,
choisissent de rendre leur travail public plus facilement.
Par exemple, en rendant leur travail utilisable gracieusement
pour une utilisation non commerciale, amateur, et seulement pour cela.
Ensuite, nous avons besoin que les sociétés
qui construisent cette culture read-write saisissent cette occasion
pour que cette écologie du contenu libre, ou plus libre,
puisse grandir sur une base neutre où les deux choix cœxistent,
de façon à ce que le plus libre concurrence le moins libre
et qu'à l'occasion de ce développement de la créativité
ils tirent leçon l'un de l'autre.
En principe, je devrais là parler d'une solution que je connais bien,
mais je ne vais pas faire ici ma publicité, je m'en abstiendrais donc.
En revanche, je vais juste vous rappeler ce que BMI nous a appris.
Le choix des artistes est la clé, pour développer le potentiel économique de ces technologies
et nous devons construire ce choix des artistes
si ces technologies doivent avoir une chance.
Mais je veux finir avec une chose bien plus importante que l'aspect économique :
comment tout cela touche nos enfants.
Il faut bien admettre qu'ils sont différents. Nous c'était ça, non ?
(Rires)
Nous avions les cassettes, ils ont les remix.
Nous regardions la télé, ils font la télé.
C'est la technologie qui les a rendus différents,
et en la voyant évoluer, nous devons bien admettre qu'on ne peut tuer
sa logique, nous ne pouvons que la criminaliser.
Nous ne pouvons en priver nos enfants, seulement la cacher.
Nous ne pouvons pas rendre nos enfants passifs,
seulement en faire des « pirates ». Est-ce le bon choix ?
Nous vivons à cette époque étrange, une prohibition où des pans de nos vies
sont en désaccord avec la loi.
Des gens normaux le vivent.
Nous l'infligeons à nos enfants.
Ils vivent en sachant que c'est à l'encontre de la loi.
C'est extraordinairement corrosif, extraordinairement corrompant.
Dans une démocratie, nous devrions pouvoir faire mieux.
Faire mieux, au moins pour eux, et à défaut, pour l'opportunité économique.
Merci de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)